[Musique]
il
bienvenue pour ce nouveau numéro de v y
paissent sur tv 78 nous sommes
aujourd'hui au sein de l'école troisième
à elancourt l'institut de l'image et du
son avec thierry perrot bonjour donc je
remercie de nous recevoir ici vous êtes
tous nouveaux fraîchement nommé
directeur de l'enseignement animations
jeux vidéo on se fait donc dans votre
établissement recruté pour donner une
nouvelle dimension à cette filière
expert reconnu du jeu vidéo que vous
êtes on va évoquer votre parcours dans
un instant déjà sur l'école ici il ya
deux types de formation il ya un master
et un bachelor qui sont proposés c'est
simple il ya deux types de formations et
elles sont aujourd'hui
autour de l'art l'art graphique en
particulier l'animation et il ya une
petite partie game design aussi c'est un
métier qui évolue très vite c'est à dire
que la formation doit s'adapter très
très vidéo il faut très faux ça change
tous les ans on va dire voilà il ya des
évolutions continuelle
rien d'un point de vue des logiciels par
exemple ou là ça ça explose tous les ans
aujourd'hui par exemple d'un point de
vue graphique on utilise énormément de
commandes de logiciels qui sont utilisés
aussi bien dans des feuilletons comme le
mandat lauriane par yolande qu'on
connaît et on les utilise ces des
logiciels qui ont du temps réel qui sont
à la base pour le jeu vidéo et qui
deviennent aujourd'hui aussi pour le
signal qu'ils sont utilisés pour le
cinéma pour le pour le jeu vidéo pour
des tas de dans des tas de domaines
quand on apprend le jeu vidéo on apprend
des choses très différentes et j'imagine
qu'il ya plusieurs métiers aussi au sein
de la filière parce qu'on peut à la fois
faire le codage le graphisme du design
alors là il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
métiers différents dans le jeu vidéo
aujourd'hui on a énormément aujourd'hui
ne faisait pas tous à 3e et les avoir
bientôt
aujourd'hui voilà il ya dans le jus dans
le jeu vidéo il ya quasiment autant de
de métier que dans le cinéma voilà on a
des producteurs
comment une filière produits soeur une
filière game design évidemment ça c'est
la principale
filière a évidemment où là on va faire
de la 2d et de la 3d on a les deux deux
types de visuels et puis on a également
la le prg à la programmation le gameplay
programme un programmeur qui est un
mélange de game design et de
programmation qui vous courent chercher
aujourd'hui on a il y en a tellement
enfin voilà le sound design évidemment
j'allais beaucoup mais quand même ce qui
fait en général on dit toujours un peu
50% de la réussite d'un jeu c'est le son
c'est très important voilà on a tout
c'est finir là qui sont dans dans le jeu
vidéo il y en a énormément et des tas de
métiers après qui viry
vous avez plus de 30 ans d'expérience
dans le domaine du jeu vidéo wii qu'est
ce qui vous a marqué le plus dans les
élèves les évolutions de ces dernières
années aujourd'hui on joue partout où
tout le temps à des choses très
différentes avec des très beaux vins
avec des portables avec des consoles de
dernière génération moi je suis toujours
émerveillé puisque j'ai vu une tout
début bon j'ai vu le le lancement du jeu
avec des atari vcs avec des vieilles
très vieilles machines et puis l'arcade
aussi bon
donc moi je suis émerveillé à chaque
fois qu'il ya une nouveauté same same
same same touche aussi j'ai souvenir par
exemple la première playstation quand
elle est sortie la toute première
playstation j'étais à delphine software
et en était on allait se lancer sur la
fabrication la production moto racer et
je me souviens d'été toute l'équipe
quand on a vu les premières images de la
playstation chez nous on jouait à ridge
racer particulier on a pleuré on était
on avait je n'ai encore aujourd'hui
on a on a vu on a vu un jeu d'arcade à
la maison pour la première fois et ça
c'était fou parce que sur des choses
vraiment en 2d avec des graphismes très
différent pour le jeu vidéo et qui bien
évidemment connaissent tout ça c'est
voilà des graphismes plus proche de
megadrive de solides et saône de
nintendo comme ça et aujourd'hui avait
une vraie transition et toi justement la
transition est toute faite moi ce qui
forcément j'ai ramené à l'un des
exemplaires voile et de la playstation 1
l'an dernier je vais être sorti
développé chez a décidé fine software
s'était fait to black y avoir 6 hybrides
notamment oui j'étais directeur
artistique dessus et plein de révolution
avec ce jeu oui bah beaucoup puisque on
le sait peu mais en fait fait to black
c'est le tout premier jeu avec une
caméra à la troisième personne on a
beaucoup parlé tomb raider de résident
evil et tout ça mais en fait non c'est
fait to black est sorti en premier c'est
à une création de paul cuisset
directeur de delphine software à
l'époque et bah c'est lui qui a eu cette
idée d'avoir une caméra à la troisième
personne et puis bah vous voulez partir
dans la 3d quoi puisque l'on voyait puis
que la playstation pouvait le faire et
c'est la première fois aussi qu'on a
textures et des personnages en amis des
textures sur le personnage on a essayé
de faire quelque chose qui était un peu
supérieur parce qu'il est déjà été déjà
sorti sur pc et on l'a essayé de
l'améliorer l'améliorer sur playstation
ça fait partie des jeux sur lesquels
vous avez travaillé avec sa foire vous
rêvez cité motoriste heures il ya eu un
flash back à ossages par exemple surtout
flash gravées de ce que vous me disiez
avant d'éviter les enregistrements bah
oui enfin on fait en fait ensuite à
flash back en ce moment parce que ma
particularité c'est que je m'occupe de
l'école mais je continue à produire des
jeux constamment et ça c'est important
pour les étudiants parce que je vais
pouvoir leur proposer des stages leur
proposer des tas de choses et ça va être
voilà ça va être intéressant pour eux
d'avoir aussi cette vision c'est que je
suis toujours dans le métier voilà je
continue à faire des jeux et là j'en
fais un sur playstation 5 ces flashbacks
demain c'est à dire que je vis dès
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas dire c'était
mieux avant même s'il ya une passion
pour le retrogaming même si des fois
identique sur le jeu vidéo d'aujourd'hui
va aider scénario des fois des choses
très très belle mais peut-être plus
simple on n'est pas sur les mêmes
mécanismes
aujourd'hui il ya il ya de magnifiques
jeux des jeux d'une beauté absolue mais
je parle pas que visuel je parle d'un
point de vue du descendu sens profond de
gamme il ya de la poésie dans le jeu
vidéo mais ça on n'en parle pas parce
qu'on parle toujours on va vous parler
de call of duty de
fighter ii fifa tout ça alors que le jeu
vidéo c'est bien plus complexe que ça
aujourd'hui il ya des jeux vidéo
d'auteurs comme au cinéma voilà et ses
jeux vidéo là bas ils sont assez
exceptionnelles on appelle ça les jeux
indépendants
etc des merveilles absolue il ya des
jeux d'un d'une force qui apportent des
émotions
comme jamais comme on peut trouver en
lisant un livre comment on peut toujours
aller voir un film comme pour regarder
une série écouter une musique ça il ya
la même chose aujourd'hui dans le jeu
vidéo mais on n'en parle pas et ça c'est
bien dommage parce que on préfère parler
des jeux qui font des millions et des
millions dhs alors que cela ils sont
extraordinaires voilà c'est eux qui
apportent ailleurs la nouveauté parce
qu'aujourd'hui les gros jeux les gros
triple à ce qu on appelle
ça stagne un peu voilà ça tourne un peu
en rond il ya quelques personnes qui
quelques studios qui arrive à faire
pousser des choses un peu plus loin mais
ça reste assez plan plan pour le moment
et il serait temps d' avec la puissance
des machines qu'on a maintenant on peut
faire des choses absolument
extraordinaire mais alors justement les
élèves vous voulez pousser vers cette
voie là et vous leur dites n'y a pas que
les triple à découper votre paiement où
il fait la différence aujourd'hui c'est
d'avoir cette petite étincelle de
creative aussi exactement ça c'est ce
que recherche en particulier tous les
industries je veux dire en particulier
aujourd'hui on est une véritable
industrie
l'industrie numéro un du loisir
d'ailleurs et c'est c'est important que
tous ces jeunes qu'ils soient créatifs
voilà il faut faut de la créativité faut
pas s'inspirer de ce qui existe déjà
mais essayer de trouver d'autres chemins
et pour ça il faut une grande culture
générale ça c'est un truc un peu
particulier c'est que on veut des
personnes qui rentrent 3ds ou même dans
d'autres écoles je vous dirais pas que
nous il y en a plein mais ce qu'on veut
tous c'est des gens qui ont une culture
générale assez exceptionnel pour pouvoir
ensuite la culture générale qui fait
qu'on est créatif une dernière question
votre jeu de cheveux fous alors j'aurai
tellement jean développer des programmes
jeunesse vous jouer ce barrage je joue
quatre heures par jour à partir de
9h30 10h le soir quand tout le monde est
couché la maison eh bien je me lance
dans tout ce qui sort en fait je lui
aussi bien des jeux téléphone qui a des
jeux sur pc bien sûr sur ps1 qu'en ce
moment je joue à quoi ghostwire
tokyo désolé pour l'anglais je suis pas
très bons en anglais mais j'ai joué à
elle donne ring c'est
voilà il ya plein de jeux j'aime
beaucoup le flight simulator qui est
sûre sur xbox série x vous avez toutes
les machines à la maison à wil ancien au
passage en plus je donne des cours
d'histoire du jeu vidéo et donc
j'apporte aux étudiants toutes les
machines de l'époque pour leur faire
tester parce que c'est très important de
connaître son passé pour voir ce qu'on
peut faire et je leur amène qu'il aura
fait essayer les machines ça c'est
important qu'ils les essayent qui joue
avec pour voir un peu ce que ce que
donne tous et s'est donné tous ces jeux
là merci beaucoup qui a ripé renault
avoir reçu ici à l'école avec 3ds aura
peut-être l'occasion de revenir par un
jeu vidéo plusieurs détails et puis la
formation est dispensée donc ici dans
cette école située sur le secteur de des
longs cours on se retrouve bientôt sur
tv 78
[Musique]